This is the death of socrates by shock.
Louis divvied completed in 1787.
It is an exemplar of the neoclassical
period in France which divvied virtually
created and brought to the fore himself.
Before I say more,
it's important to note just how striking
this canvas is,
not knowing anything about it,
so much jumps out at me right away.
The clarity of the scene,
the fierce gesture of the man in the
middle,
the interplay of the Chalice and the
hand that reaches for it,
the angles of the light and the men,
the soft draping,
garments bear flat stone wall.
As the title suggests,
the scene depicts the death of socrates
told famously by Plato in his dialogue
on the soul,
the Fito.
Socrates had been convicted in Athenian
Court of failing to acknowledge the gods
of the city and corrupting the city's
youth and sentenced to death by drinking
hemlock.
As Plato makes clear in another
dialogue,
the crito.
Socrates could have escaped into exile,
but instead he chooses to die.
Taking the opportunity to teach his
final lesson that death is not to be
feared by the philosopher,
but embraced as an apotheosis of the
soul divvied chooses to paint the moment
just as socrates is grabbing for the
poison draft he's been discussing at
length the immortality of the soul and
doesn't even seem to care that he's
about to take the implement of his death
in hand.
On the contrary,
socrates is defined gesturing toward the
afterlife,
to which he hastens divvied idealizes
him.
Socrates would have been 70 at the time
in somewhat less muscular and beautiful
than painted here.
The raking light coming in from the top
left pours onto socrates the brightest
figure in the tablo.
The colors are muted at the sides,
become vivid in the center with the
executioner in red and socrates in
white.
For Davita.
Socrates is a symbol of strength,
over passion,
of STOIC commitment to an abstract
principle,
even in the face of death.
This is the ethical message divvied
sought to offer the French two years
before the French revolution,
as the monarchy was in decline and
reformers ache to install a democracy
akin to that.
Of Socrates own time in Greek antiquity
or of the United States,
which had just executed its own
revolution five years prior,
indeed Thomas Jefferson himself was
present at the unveiling of this
painting at the salon of 1787.
The image commissioned by two radical
political reformers was wildly popular,
divvied had already made his name with
another severe moralistic canvas,
the oath of the ratio which effectively
invented the neoclassical taking its
cues from the stark simplicity of
ancient Greece and Rome from the ancient
obsession with anatomy and musculature
from the two dimensional freezes
depicting historical events
neoclassicism as rendered by divvied
made its points strongly and severely.
This was in direct opposition to the
dominant Rococo style that reflected the
ornate and hedonistic lifestyles of the
monarchy in the horatio pie.
As in the death of socrates.
Those dedicated to principal are
depicted with angular geometry.
While those ruled by passion are curved
and weak in both canvases,
the backgrounds are flat,
fixing attention on the foreground where
like a freeze,
the action can be read from site to
site.
One way to read the death of socrates is
right to left the anguish of socrates
followers,
curling and twisting opens up onto the
comm expression of the man himself and
flows down through his right arm which
hovers over the cup of poison,
the space between the hand and the cup.
The exact center of the image is the
seat of maximum narrative charge.
Then it falls back into the pain of the
man who delivers the poison,
who turns his gaze away from socrates
and finally comes to rest on the man
sitting at the foot of the bed,
unengaged were on him in a moment.
Davita doesn't identify anyone in the
painting,
but we can infer from accounts of
socrates actual death.
That in the background is socrates.
Wife is an anthropy,
led away in distress and collecting.
Socrates leg is cryto,
his oldest and most faithful student
under credo.
We can see that divvied has signed his
own name,
signaling a feeling of connection with
the man divvied weaker than his ideal of
moral strength.
Nonetheless grabs and strives toward it.
The painter has taken a number of
liberties with history besides altering
socrates face and physique divvied
decreases the number of people present
at the event from over 15 to 12 echoing
the number of disciples at De Vinci's
last supper,
but I think the most significant change
is that the addition of the character at
the foot of the bed.
This is plato,
the man who popularized socrates
teachings by staging him as the
protagonists in over 30 philosophical
dialogues put simply without plato,
there would be no socrates.
The two men melt into each other
historically.
It's hard to determine where socrates
philosophy ends and Plato's begins not
only was plato absent at the death of
socrates,
but he was a young man at the time here
at Davita,
has some as old and withdrawn.
I said earlier that you can read the
canvas from right to left,
but you can also read it from left to
right.
The whole scene,
it seems to me,
appears to explode out of the back of
Plato's head,
recontextualizing it as a memory,
an idealized memory in which socrates
gestures in the exact same way he does
in Rafael's school.
Of Athens significantly,
Plato is positioned apart from the flat
background where the frozen lateral
moment gives way to the depth of time.
In reality,
it strikes me that this is the way
memories often fall out.
Restaged with smooth edges and perfect
light,
two dimensional,
idealized,
painstakingly arranged to serve the
needs of the present in the character of
Plato.
The rigorous ethical reality of the
scene is betrayed by its own self
awareness as a construction and in only
a few short years,
the noble ideals of the French
Revolution will be betrayed as well by
the terror that is to follow.
Maybe this is why almost prophetically
divvied signs his name here,
a second time neoclassicism like this
may seem severe and blunt,
but so much is happening in David's
death of socrates and interplay of
historical,
personal,
political and aesthetic elements
rendered forcefully suddenly and
beautifully put.
Another way,
it's a work of genius.
Hey everybody,
if you want to help me keep making these
videos and support the nerdwriter,
you can visit my patrion page by
clicking here.
You can pledge as little as $1.
Everything helps.
Thank you so much.
Here's some more videos.